[Music]
is it just me or does Squidward's house
look like the cursed Tiki doll from the
fourth season premiere of The Brady
Bunch Hawaii bound I guess if you're
gonna rip off someone rip off from the
best or the Brady Bunch
why would Squidward need an actual
clarinet when the opening makes it clear
that these creatures can play their own
noses how exactly the books work in an
underwater environment do they have
special waterproof pages does everyone
just get used to soggy paper and if so
how do they turn the pages without
tearing them yeah yeah it's a cartoon
but they drew books on the bookshops oh
damn not me also electrical audio
equipment underwater what would you even
listen to on this the Beach Boys The
Strokes not a surf land lines sea lions
sea lions why is there visible spit
shooting from his mouth and dropping
Lynn even if you could see it in the
water it would just be floating in front
of him I'm beginning to think this
cartoon isn't actually concerned with
the actual ramifications of living in a
pineapple under the seat I do have a
band and we're gonna play that character
tells a lie out of Pride and then spends
the rest of the episode trying to make
that lie true cliche good luck next
Tuesday I hope the audience brings lots
of have you perfect question why would
squilliam fancy-son from band class call
and offer this primo gig to someone who
they think sucks at playing music the
episode seems to indicate that the
squilliam fancy-son from band class
wants to prove that Squidward doesn't
actually have a band and works in fast
food but aren't there better way a
squilliam fancy-son from band class
could find this out that don't involve
putting his own reputation on the line
I've got to drum up a marching band fast
drum band band humor the most simple
part of this ad isn't the fact that it
says practice begins tonight 8:30 sharp
even though it never specifies the
actual date it's that it doesn't even
give any contact info or address also
reading practice begins tonight I just
want to confirm the joke here is that
Squidward's snuck into people's homes
and posted this ad in their showers and
I have to say that's brilliant marketing
you're telling me you wouldn't remember
it if you got in the shower and an ad
was taped to your wall or a star
advertising our podcast this way and if
we get caught I'm using the Squidward
offense
instrument no Patrick mayonnaise is not
an instrument have to disagree there
squiddy / some mayonnaise is an
instrument that makes your intestines
play all kinds of awful music rice
section go I'm not going to spend time
ridiculing that all these instruments
came from nowhere or that these
inexperienced musicians could suddenly
play them by ear
I mean I'm going to send those things
sure but I'm not going to ridicule them
but I am gonna really cool is how
insufferable the spatial continuity is
in this scene first the show makes the
mistake of giving a full overhead shot
to use against it so in the brass
section plays from the front row we can
clearly point out that they're actually
way in the back here also what's up with
the lipstick whale playing a saxophone
in the brass section that thing has more
wooden wind to it than the porn and
beans festival I hosted last Christmas
and did you know this characters name is
pearl crabs feral crabs that's not a
cartoon character that's a gender
specific STD and when we finally get to
the winds which comes love playing those
things underwater they also shown as the
front row and they - or towards the back
and the drums well they apparently think
they have to blow their own sticks cuz
hardy are and are not even the same
drums we see in the front row to begin
with because of course mr. Squarepants
has to be front and center
and where's Patrick he was two sponges
left here but it's nowhere to be seen
here and why is the only the trombone
here but the brass section here also
sandy crack or whatever her name is is
to Patrick's left here but then in a
completely different section bigger and
here I swear this show might actually
break me when they ask who finally took
out mr. sins you can tell him it was the
squishy cube of yellow who eventually
did the deed this is our last night
together before the show and I know that
you haven't improved since we began I
get they still can't play instruments
four days later but in that time no one
has shared with Patrick that his
instrument is not food I have a theory
people talk loud when they want to act
smart right I have no idea what this
[ __ ] is talking about
well maybe we wouldn't sound so bad if
some people didn't try to play with big
meaty claws random fish saxophonist
would be fantastic at TV since oh so now
the talking cheese is gonna preach to us
his name is spongebob not cheese bomb so
how does that even make sense
wow you did it you took my one chance at
happiness
maybe but Squidward should really put
that teleportation ability to good use
hello did he get
outside the door when it was closed it
was just in the room with him
Squidward's always been there for us
when it was convenient for him Evelyn
when your little Jimmy was trapped in a
fire co rescued him a fireman okay fine
this shows dumb but occasionally we
really funny take the sin off but don't
expect anymore they're just gonna have
to find another band to play
Squidward doesn't really you think the
band is showing up why is even here let
alone at the band entrance
why is squilliam fancy-son from band
class joining them on the stage for an
event he told the organizers he couldn't
attend with a band he never expected to
be real planning committee for the
bubble bowl should be fired immediately
you see you can see so humans are just
fully aware of Spongebob and company and
just roll with it there's not enough
alcohol in the world that would cause
this kind of universal acceptance
amongst a crowded football stadium
[Applause]
okay here's the thing about fandom it
can take something amazing turn it into
something more that it is and then get
mad when the rest of the world doesn't
understand the next 90 seconds of this
rock ballad halftime performance is
truly wonderful so much so that when
fans rallied to actually have it played
at the Super Bowl as a tribute to the
late spongebob creator Stephen
Hillenburg the NFL actually did use some
of it but not enough for some fans so is
this a sin for the NFL for spongebob
fans for expecting too much from maroon
5 for me interrupting the stream of
jokes to actually bring it up whichever
you like but I think we all know the
real sweet victory here were the memes
we made along the way do you think it's
possible that your mom won't love you
anymore if she sees how bad you're
losing in the game make sure you click
that Bell icon but clicking the little
bell icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it and we're supposed to play
the bubble bowl next week and one time
at band camp how do you like that fancy
boy
okay now how many of you have played
musical instruments before think me
think okay try to repeat after me last
section go sounds sexy
Rick where'd you get a hand grenade I
don't know
I really had expected better of you babe
Oh what do you mean you people
[Music]